isn't that what dante is
really
aiming for
is first to see the heart as it is
and to purge it
so that it is pure and strong and great
capable of loving god and others well
capable of seeing god
[Music]
the mountain is threefold
first group those who love what is wrong
second group those who love
insufficiently
third group those who love excessively
this brings me to
the point of this class which is what is
purgation for dante what is he doing and
what's the point
of the poem
if we don't learn to love well dante
suggests in the best order
we will not be able to live well
we will not be able to live greatly
we will not be able to live actually as
god wants the human being to live
so purgation
is meant to be
this
profound educational and formational
experience
whereby we learn finally completely
how to love
god
ourself others
how to love
greatly
and well
so why don't souls just go straight
to paradiso wouldn't that be a lot more
efficient i mean why all this circling
why this need to
straighten love out
to purify it to purge it
surely he'd be better off
taking an express train to parody so
man fred let's get those wounds fixed
but dante presents it otherwise
he presents this middle kingdom as being
a good thing it's being a helpful thing
and being what human beings need
if they've died
without
what
their loves in
this kind of order
so dante believes in habituation
he believes in character
i didn't mention this line in inferno
but at one point virgil says
dante have you forgotten your ethics by
aristotle
so dante is
aristotelian in this way
he believes in habit and character
now he also believes in repentance as we
can see from the buon kante story or
from the manfred story or from so many
others
in purgatory
so what happens after
we repent
of sin or of evil
what kind of life follows that
so for dante what follows is the need to
live in a new way
the need for new habits
and that tends to be on this earth a
struggle that follows and that requires
time
and effort and persistence and patience
and so too here in the middle part of
the poem
the old habits
of the soul
the old wounds
they need to be put aside the wounds
need to be healed
and the soul needs to become thoroughly
habituated to that new life
so thoroughly habituated not to pride
not to envy not to wrath not the sloth
not the avarice not to gluttony not to
lust
in order to do so
the soul needs
god's grace
the soul needs to want that the soul
needs time
and then the soul needs what happens on
each of these terraces
and dante presents purgation in a
slightly different way on each terrace
it's very beautiful
you have
prayer
you have
art
you have a restoration of human
relationships so there's friendship on
the mountain there's community on the
mountain you're restored to relationship
with other people that isn't proud
envious wrathful
so this is purgation as dante presents
it
and this is what the soul needs to
complete
the process
and be fit and ready to stand in the
presence of god
[Music]
you